it started as a legend one of the  greatest of all thousand years who've  kept it hidden to protect her what is  destined to arrive Optimus Prime  you destroyed your home in the present  moneymaker I do  [Music]  your daughter what would you say to her  brush your teeth work hard stay away  from any boy in a band especially a  drummer  these are trouble times without leaders  Chaos Rings  two worlds colliding  you're all that stand in its way and how  the greatest mission of the mall  returned the type of human history  right now keep it  [Applause]  the imminent destruction of everything  we know and love begins  [Music]  leaving you  when all seems lost a few great Souls  [Music]  and everything we've ever known the  operation is over when I keep it up a  bribe okay  on the face  and I once like this  [Music]  for my world to live  yours must die  you  [Music]  you